So the first major component we're going to dive
into to help, is the HTML5 Application Cache. This let's
you provide a local cache of HTML files, CSF, JavaScript,
images, any other resources your client webapp may use. And
get the browser to use them even before it tries
to hit the network. So let's take a look at
how this works and how we can use it. The
application cache is a manifest that you point to from
inside your HTML element. Let's take a look
at the cache manifest for our conference application. The
manifest starts with a magic header, cache manifest Lines
that start with a hash sign are actually comments.
Typically, the second line is a comment with some
kind of cache version string. More on that later.
But this is followed by a cache section. Now
what do you think goes in the cache section?
Should it be every file that's on the servers file system? Every resource
that can be statically served, or should it be a collection of cat videos?